the wind's really picking up yeah it is  hey so what the hell happened like do  you have anything you need to report no  I know no smoke on my end can you  confirm yes are you concerned about the  Greenwood fire that wasn't should I be  well the wind is really picking up it's  two and a half miles off and it's gonna  have to break at the canyon right all  right well use your best judgment should  I be worried  Delilah should I be worried  no Henry so last night you know we  shouldn't talk about it please stop I  don't give a [ __ ]  please fine I don't think I'm I don't  think we're safe this job's not safe  don't be dramatic do people die out here  people die getting out of the shower you  know what I mean as a lookout  look why are we even here to make sure  the damn wilderness doesn't burn down no  our job is to be here when that happens  Henry there are some things you can't  prevent so just stay in your tower okay  stay in there and watch  you  [Music]